Welcome to Epic Games Online Training.
My name is Sean Lake
and I'm one of the instructors here at Epic Games.
And I'll be taking you through the Twinmotion Quickstart.
I'll be diving into your very first project
in version 2025, which at this point is the most recent.
This course is intended for those
who are either new to Twinmotion
or just want to start from fresh.
So what we'll be going through
will be what we show today.
What is Twinmotion, who is it for?
As well as we'll be looking at some of the templates
and some of the new ones that have been added.
We'll get to know our UI within Twinmotion
and going through and importing our own assets
or working with Twinmotion assets.
We'll also be working briefly with materials,
setting up some lighting to determine
how we want our mood to be set.
Then we'll be moving into seasons changing
as well as at the end, we'll be sharing our project
or rather showing us how to show our project.
And finally, we'll wrap up with the final of everything
that we have covered.
So let's not wait any longer, let's get started.